what is a perfect day in the life
perfectly productive day in the life of
Mr Beast look like
oh boy well I mean or like a stand I
mean the perfectly productive day as we
film our main Channel video because
those get 100 million a pop I mean it
doesn't really get any better than that
what about like the average day when
you're not on the set yeah and you're
like like because you're running a lot
of things right yeah so right now we
have our snack brand festivals we have a
restaurant chain Beast burger and then
we basically which we haven't even
really launched any products yet but we
have the the data company that I was
showing you where we're gonna roll out
some tools for creators and then we have
the reacts channel the gaming channel
the main Channel then we have my charity
which also has a channel
um and so kind of how I've structured my
life right now uh is whatever I have
free time we just kind of go hey guys
Jimmy's got an hour from 2PM to 3 P.M
and it's everyone's just like I need
this I need this and this Channel's like
I need this thing filmed or you know
whatever the guy who runs on tick tocks
like I need this Tick Tock filmer
um you know Beast Burger is like I need
this menu item approved do we need to
talk about this marketing thing and then
we kind of just look at what everyone
needs and we're like that one looks like
the most important we'll do that and
then so it's just kind of like you know
if I just did that for every company in
a day then that's optimal like just kind
of like an optimal day for me would be
going down the eight companies and just
whatever they're like two to three
biggest pain points or things they need
from me and just doing those based on
priority and then trying to keep it as
short as possible yeah to just the
things that you're needed on it doesn't
get more optimal than that if I clear
the bottlenecks or some bottlenecks for
all my companies then it's yes that's a
perfect day yeah I mean even just me
because you're like you're showing me
around and you're being a great and
gracious host but on top of that you're
just doing all these meetings you you
basically I felt bad at some points I
was like oh I just tricked him into
going to meetings with me he's like my
little meeting buddy yeah I mean it was
it was fun it's fun to see it it was fun
to see how
effectively you've delegated
you basically trust the team to do a
really good job on the various things
and there's just a strong team that's
able to
carry the five gun all the different
tasks yeah from the from the
brainstorming and the main channel to
the reacts and so on yeah it's really
interesting I mean it's it's really
interesting what it takes to build a
team like that because you very quickly
build the very large team that's that's
able to scale which is very scary
because it's my first you know I I'm 24.
you know and I think I was telling you
this earlier it's funny because six
years ago I had to raise my hand to go
use the bathroom and now I'm in charge
of hundreds of people and entertain
hundreds of millions of people and so it
is crazy just how quick it comes up and
I wish I was a little bit older so I
could have ran a couple companies and
failed a few companies in the past and
like learn from those and apply those
here because I know for a fact when I'm
34 I'm 24 now when I'm 34. I'll I'll
know so much more about running a
business and scaling and hiring and and
how to lead people and better
effectively communicate and all these
different skill sets that will make them
a better leader that uh that's the only
thing that sucks is uh I just don't have
those because I just haven't been
through the lessons and I just have such
a lucrative thing on my plate right now
and it just sucks that I have to learn
the lessons with the lucrative thing you
know what I mean yeah because you you
already have so much influence so much
impact but you have effectively scaled
what what lessons do you draw from that
how to effectively scale as a 24 year
old like yeah that's something I feel
like I actually could give a lot of
value to to young people who are doing
it like older people who've built five
companies or whatever they do
um I probably couldn't you know they're
gonna be like oh this is so obvious but
um for uh younger first-time business
owners you kind of just experiment to be
honest and uh but for us like it's just
a new space no one had really ever
skilled up a 100 person team to build
make content on YouTube so there wasn't
no uh I spent all this time like I hired
one person from Disney to at one point
to come in and help and obviously that
was a dumb idea looking back on it but
you know I thought oh they make great
stuff people want to watch and they come
over here and help me build a team and
you know they build it more the
traditional way and not like how it
should be online and and so then it's
like okay and now I'm not trying to
trash people like they all tried their
best but then I try hire this one person
who does this different type of uh media
and runs a 100 person team and then you
come in here and they try to build it
that way they don't really listen to you
or value or or see the difference and I
I tried basically for building this
company with like four or five different
people who worked in different veins of
media and you know every single time I
just like they just don't get it and
they like they don't understand my world
and the the eventual solution was just
like draw up my sleeves and do it myself
you know with like James where I hit man
and just like no no one's ever done this
and like No One's Gonna just give us a
golden carrot and tell us how to build
this company we got to figure the [ __ ]
out ourselves and you have to kind of
build up people from scratch then yeah
exactly all the stuff I was talking
about earlier and all the the lessons I
learned along the way
um and Sophie for me that was a big part
of like and try to stop trying to have
someone build this company for me and
just do it myself because it's scary
like my whole life studying YouTube
videos of virality not business building
but [ __ ] I was like I guess we just got
to do it ourselves and
um and that's where things really start
to click and we got the exponential
growth we started getting the right
people and training them the right way
and you know just throwing conventional
stuff out the door and focusing on
what's actually practical for YouTube
which is just completely different than
traditional media
so you train people and then those
people train people and and so on yeah I
mean it's just even like you know how
you do the lighting on sets or like how
you do the audio or or um you know not
writing scripts so you know we're just
not as efficient with our filming like
sometimes I have to have 30 cameras
running why because it's not scripted I
don't I don't know what Chris is gonna
do when we start filming he might run
over there but guess what we got to have
it planned because there's only one shot
I can't you know tell them not to do
that yeah that's the shooting but then
there's also the editing yeah and then
the editing as well and not having
guardrails and kind of you know I at the
end of the day it's whatever I want the
video their job is to make a video that
they think I'll like because it's my
channel but you know you can achieve
that kind of however and
um and so it's just everything's just
different you know it's much more I
guess like a startup as opposed to
um are you often surprised like with the
result like
you think a certain like we watched the
video today that was really nice those
different than you would have
potentially edited yeah are you
sometimes surprised by like a decision
editor makes like okay that's not the
way I would have done it but it's
actually this is a cool idea yeah of
course yeah now um the thing my biggest
fear is I don't ever want to get trapped
in like a bubble of you know because we
are getting 100 million views of video
on the main Channel like but I don't
want to get in this feedback loop of
just my ideas are great or or not
feedback loop but stop learning and
improving because it is easy sometimes
to be like what we're doing is working
we need to just keep doing it I want to
keep learning and trying new things and
I guess one way I'd put is like you
don't when when you're on a a come up or
you're growing you don't want to uh Test
new things once uh you start to Plateau
or have a downtrend because if you're
like you know you you're skyrocketing
right you're up up and then you level
off you start to go down and you're like
oh this isn't working anymore let's
start experimenting well if you have a
bad experiment now you're in like a
tailspin you're nose diving and you have
one more bad experiment you're like
screwed kind of I'm oversimplify you
want to test things while you're still
growing to keep the growing from
happening because once you like have you
know again very oversimplifying that
like you know kind of level off you do a
couple tests that go wrong am I you're
like screwed you know you're already out
the door now you're just confirming that
you're out the door an online
entertainment so that's kind of how I
see it so I think it's very imperative
that you're constantly always
experimenting and trying things even if
you're getting crazy unheard of growth